la décision vient de tomber le conseil
constitutionnel valide l'essentiel du
projet de loi de lutte contre le
séparatisme et ne sont sûrs que deux
dispositions institution avait été saisi
par une soixantaine de députés de gauche
comme de droite pour en panne on
retrouve notre reporter nadège à terssac
la neige on vient de l'apprendre le
conseil constitutionnel valide la
majorité de la loi
absolument et ce n'est pas une surprise
ce texte définitivement adopté par le
parlement le 23 juillet dernier après
sept mois de débats houleux à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat alors
saisi par des députés et sénateurs de
gauche comme de droite est les sages ont
donc conforté ce texte renommée respect
des valeurs de la république les sages
n'ont censuré un vous l'avez dit que
deux mesures sur les dissolutions
d'associations ou encore les retraits de
titre de séjour accordés aux étrangers
des mesures qui ne porte pas sur des
dispositions majeures donc porté par le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
ce texte a dès le départ suscité la
polémique auprès de la société civile
des communautés religieuses et dans la
sphère politique et pour cause beaucoup
s'accordent à dire en effet que le texte
met à mal les équilibres de la loi de
1905 qu'il porterait atteinte aux
libertés de culte d'opinion et
d'association alors gérald darmanin
rapidement a réagi après l'adoption de
ce projet de loi par le conseil
constitutionnel il a réagi notamment sur
twitter un je cite ce texte voulu par
emmanuel macron permettra de lutter avec
force grâce à de nouvelles armes contre
ceux qui veulent porter atteinte à la
laïcité notre bien commun voilà donc
pour cette réaction du ministre de
l'intérieur qui datent de tout juste une
trentaine de minutes à peine merci à la
neige pour toutes ces précisions